speaking of not being allowed to exist
you want to do that to private school
less controversial well yeah but you say
you shut them down
well i you know i don't say shut them
down but i say the ones at the very very
top of the system the ones that cost
thirty five to fifty thousand dollars a
year
that they've become kind of a malign
force in america they
hoover up all that you know the huge
number of spots in the ivy league
schools
they have you know exeter has 1.3
billion dollars we don't get any tax
money
exeter exeter it's a big one where is
that a fancy one
i wouldn't know private schools i just
went to a regular school in new jersey
okay i think i'm happy you got a show
yeah that's right
berkeley high school yeah they're you
look like you were born on a tennis
court where did you go to school
i went to a fancy private school you did
yeah i went to a school in massachusetts
called middlesex which i thought was
a wonderful school and still think is a
wonderful school and i think some of
these schools do
extraordinary jobs in in really
educating people from a much bigger
they've changed a lot you were there i'm
sorry but they have and this is
a lot of what your article about i also
read barry weiss's article about harvard
westlake
and i mean i've been talking about this
on the show taking a lot of for
target about it but it's true there is
something going on
in the schools and you're right these
are the schools that funnel kids to
harvard and harvard
you know funnels them out to the
important parts of the media
television government and
they control a lot of how people think
so
um two things that are different parents
don't have the back of the teachers
anymore they always side with their
little brat
that's different and the biggest thing i
think is the shift away
from moral teaching from the parent to
the school
used to be the the school would be
afraid of what the parent
thought now the parent is afraid of
going against what they're teaching in
school even when they don't agree with
it
right that's a huge shift that we should
stop and
at least notice and debate and talk
about right
of course and you know in these private
schools well
that's not such a big issue in the sense
that you don't have to send your child
to that school
nobody's holding your gun to your head
and saying you have to go to a fancy
school
but when we have public schools
thousands and thousands of public
schools
where parents are are really afraid to
challenge what's going on in the
classroom
that's really a problem that's really a
a serious problem in education but
i think it's a problem throughout
education which is that we're losing the
distinction between
what education is and what
indoctrination is yes and a lot of
what's happening is really just
indoctrination
like you know i i studied marxism in
school it's important to understand what
marxism is
it's different from being taught from a
marxist perspective right
one exposes you to ideas the other makes
you
a kind of a soldier in a given in a
given perspective
and that's like that's there's something
kind of totalitarian about that you're
producing like
not independent thinkers you're
producing red guards you're producing
cadres
and it's so grotesque at the wealthy
schools where here are these like
children of actual billionaires
being turned into baby marxists because
that's how rich your daddy has to be for
marxism to work for you personally as a
you know
as a theory so the whole thing is and
that's another
american issue you know we've got to
pull together and we've got to
you know we've got to lift up this whole
idea of education and get
some of this crap out of the schools we
just have to
i what i read in some of your article
summon barry's is that there is this
climate of fear that people are living
in schools fear of not being woke enough
of not speaking woken up she says power
in america comes from speaking woke
there she quotes this math teacher who
says i am in a cult
well not exactly it's that the cult is
all around me and i'm trying to save
kids from becoming members
she says it sounds like he's a
scientology defector
well i think right now we're in sort of
a a certain period that i think is
hopefully going to be short-lived and
that schools have been reacting very
quickly
and very hugely to the social protests
over the summer which kids
thank god we're very moved by and we're
very much a part of
and so that's important but the lessons
that they're introducing
on the backs of that protest are
grotesque yeah and also the climate of
fear is not just in schools
it's throughout institutions companies
all over all over the country and people
have to start
calling on it i mean the only
way this ends is
people who are in authority say no we're
not going to be bullied if you don't
want to work here
go elsewhere these are our values and
we're going to stick by them they
include
fair play and openness to a variety of
points of view
you